[Music]
do you have any superstitious rituals at
bay you know a lot of athletes but I
think particularly pitchers it's all
about your mindset yeah
what are your rituals what do you like
to do every time you pitch uh let's see
well you know where every five days so
in between normal stuff but then the
night before as you can tell by my
amazing physique
I eat Taco Bell and every night you eat
Taco Bell the night before you pitch
every time we start yes
you're welcome Taco Bell yeah it also
results in your in your game day
diarrhea tradition right you're welcome
top
so you talk about what do you I'm
curious you get a specific food at Taco
Bell or anything at specific food same
thing every time three crunchy taco
Supremes no tomato cheesy gordita crunch
and a Mexican pizza no tomato every time
so you just don't like tomatoes yeah you
get that yeah yeah I'm getting some
picking up on that yeah you did
something you know we just mentioned a
second ago old timey baseball players
you brought back something from the old
days that I had not seen in a long time
I don't even think it's existed in my
generation the hotfoot well you it's a
prank that you like to play on other
players no the hotfoot is when you you
light a match I mean the classic was you
stick a match yeah in someone's shoe and
light it on fire when they're not
looking
okay yep and you decided to bring this
back yeah yeah yeah and to a whole new
level you know so Bert Blyleven we're
playing at Minnesota Bert Blyleven for
all you know who don't know was just
inducted to the Hall of Fame right and
we're playing in Minnesota so of course
the hot foots on my mind they're always
showing videos of him doing it he used
to do it yeah used to like guys like
shoelaces he right there little
shoelaces gonna be a little tiny little
flame so uh I took it to another level
and and went and got some athletic tape
and doused it and tape remover which is
highly flammable wrap that and some gum
and stick it on the back of my buddy Don
Kelly shoe right and proceeded to light
it when he's not looking so instead of
the hot foot we got the hot leg yeah
claim is up to here yeah I actually I
saw this hot Sun SportsCenter and it
kind of blew my mind because it looks
incredibly irresponsible if you didn't
see I'm standing behind it with a cup of
water falling him around because I'm
afraid if he doesn't notice soon I'm
afraid he's just gonna go up yeah yeah
well we actually have footage of this
historic event in baseball history let's
take a look Kelly's foot is on fire oh
my goodness he still doesn't know that's
terrible good by the way
your foots on fire faithing Oh
yes I was looking at the cup of water is
really not enough if things get out of
hand yeah he goes up and becomes a fire
Walker you've got a little cup of water
yeah that's all you've got yeah yeah and
they actually he flicked it on this big
water cooler we had there and all I've
got this little cup of water thank God
it went out because if it didn't go out
I was like friends gonna blow up the
whole dugout yeah yeah it's you continue
doing this do you think yes absolutely